good afternoon my name is Maria Tyson
I'm a current junior from Newport
Michigan studying psychology and English
I'm a proud member of Kappa Kappa Gamma
women's fraternity as well as our
student Federation it is my pleasure to
introduce to you our speaker for this
afternoon Charles R Kessler Charles R
Kessler is the dangler like coma
distinguished professor of government at
Claremont McKenna College an editor of
the Claremont Review of Books dr.
Kessler received his PhD in government
from Harvard University from 1989 to
2008 he served as director of the Henry
Salvatori Center for the Study of
individual freedom in the modern world
he has written for numerous publications
including The Wall Street Journal the
Christian Science Monitor policy review
National Review the Weekly Standard in
the Claremont Review of Books he is
editor of the Signet classic edition of
the Federalist Papers co-editor with
William F Buckley Jr of keeping the
tablet modern American conservative
thought an author of I am the change
Barack Obama in the future of liberalism
please join me in welcoming to the
podium dr. Charles R Kessler
thank you for that very charming
introduction mmm Maria I appreciate it
very much and it's a great pleasure to
be here at Hillsdale which is certainly
one of my favorite colleges and it is of
course helmed by my old friend Larry
Arne whom I've known for 35 years or
something like that and and of course
I've known penny every bit as long as I
as I've known Larry and it's wonderful
to see them both and to see them
thriving at this institution which is
thriving
I mean Hillsdale is really a godsend to
American higher education and I'm happy
to be able to appear here under its its
imprimatur I have to apologize for my
voice I caught a cold in Philadelphia
it's an Eastern cold
and so it's it's weakened to be my voice
a little bit but I hope not annoyingly
and if I start to go sort of Hillary on
you I hope someone will come up and help
me
alright so Pat Caddell is a hard act to
follow and so I won't try I'm following
him in a certain sense but we're
changing subjects we're changing from
the Democratic Party to the Republican
Party and what I'd like to share with
you today are some brief observations
about the topic the history and the
principles of the Republican Party first
of all though I'll say something about
this carefully chosen topic history and
principles so in other words two
different things two sources of meaning
about things Republican on the one hand
you have
it's history a changeable story of
changeable events it might have come out
differently much depended upon the
actions of individual men and women
under the circumstances to make the
history of the modern Republican Party
on the other hand the topic points our
attention to principles some
unchangeable things the unchangeable
truths underlying the changeable events
of human history to the to human nature
and to moral reality to to the most
fundamental things to them to the moral
reality as it shines it's light on
politics now you might think it's odd to
associate permanent things like
principles moral truths laws with
something as highly impermanent or at
least informal as political parties
political parties perhaps are not as
famous for principle as they should be
it's at least true that you know in
although political parties are now rife
in the world and I don't think there's a
single regime without some sort of party
system one few or many almost nowhere is
political party or is the institution of
political party in the Constitution it's
usually informal it grew up alongside an
existing legal structure it may be
acknowledged in the statute law of a
country but it's not like a Congress or
a presidency or a prime ministership
it's not an intrinsic part of the legal
political order it exists in a certain
kind of tension with the formal legal
authority in any given society however
in America our changeable two-party
system as Jim Caesar perhaps explained
on Sunday just just a while ago
our two-party system in a sense is
underlined by a one-party system
underlying the two parties and the
disagreements that they have regularly
you could say there is a kind of
consensus there is a sense in which the
two parties are really parts of one
party and that that consensus on
underlying principles is precisely what
makes possible a peaceful party
competition we have had one notorious
one huge instance in our own history
where party competition broke down and
that was in 1860 than the beginning of
the Civil War if one of the parties or
several of the parties refused to accept
the presidential nominees election
belonging to a different party you then
have a constitutional crisis and you
have a moment when the one party system
that expresses the consensus underlying
that disagreements breaks down because
the disagreements themselves have now
become fundamental not the consensus but
the disagreements and that's what
happens in 1860 it may be given our own
highly politicized and angry times that
we might want to speculate and I will
speculate a little at the very end of
this address about what politics today
is telling us about the health of our
one party system the health of our
political consensus in this country and
whether we are also perhaps approaching
a situation where great political
disorder if not political violence lies
ahead of us I don't think we're at the
ultimate point yet but surely there are
some signs that we need to consider
seriously about the health of our
democratic system and of course what
might be done about that but to flesh
out a little bit this notion that there
is a kind of one-party consensus
underlying the two-party system in a
America let me give you two kinds of
proof the first has to do with the names
of political parties that we have
adopted in the United States Thomas
Jefferson had the first political party
organized the first political party in
American history in the early 1790s and
he called it in the beginning republican
but as a badge of honor
he eventually changed the name to the
Democratic Republican Party
acknowledging that this was that his
team so to speak was the more democratic
team in the competition and that he was
not afraid of embracing the implications
of democracy within the American
Republican order by the time of Andrew
Jackson's election in 1828 and
re-election in 1832 the name republican
had been dropped and that party had
described herself then and thereafter as
simply the Democratic Party of the
United States there was at that point no
Republican Party and the Democrats were
faced by Whigs who had sort of inherited
the Federalist Party's mantle but when
after 1854 the anti Nebraska or you
could say anti-slavery a party was
looking for a name it revived the
original name of the Jeffersonians and
called itself the Republican Party and
this was the party that would whose
first presidential candidate John C
Fremont would fail in 1856 but of course
Abraham Lincoln would be elected in 1860
he would not win by the way a majority
of the popular vote he won a majority of
the electoral college but only a
plurality of the popular vote he won
about thirty-nine point nine percent of
the popular vote in in 1860 but if you
look back at the whole history of
American parties you'll see that a few
names have completely disappeared the
Federalists and the Whigs but the very
first party that we had the Democratic
Republican Party is in a sense the only
Ardi the country has ever known we now
have half of it calling itself the
Democratic Party and the other calling
itself the Republican Party and in a
democratic republic like the United
States those divisions are to be
expected under our system we have the
Democrats tend to emphasize majorities
usually popular will the the necessity
of following popular will Republicans
like to remember the law the
Constitution restraints upon majority
power minority rights and of course for
a very long time the Republican Party
was the party of most black Americans
because it had been the party that freed
the slaves that stood up for individual
rights against local majorities in the
south and elsewhere across the Union
eventually but there is a sense still
present even if attenuated now I would
say that what Thomas Jefferson said in
his first inaugural is still true we are
all Republicans he said then we are all
Federalists speaking of the major
opposition party not every difference of
opinion is a difference of principle as
he also said Jefferson did in his
inaugural however the differences of
opinion these days in American politics
do involve I think differences of
principle and go very deep and are quite
radical when compared to most situations
in the American past now it's not just I
said to two forms of evidence one was
the history of party names but the other
is the fact that if you look at the
election results over time in American
history you see that they fall into vast
periods of one-party dominance it's not
every night every election in American
history is created equal some are much
more important than others some set a
pattern which then lasts for a
generation or two or three in our
politics let me give you a few
statistics just by way of
illustration first of all from 1801 to
1829 28 years in the beginning of our
history there is an unbroken ascendancy
of Jefferson who was elected in 1800 and
his heirs in every administration in
those 28 years across those 28 years the
secretary of state became president
after the retirement of his predecessor
there was a ladder of office you became
the secretary of state chances were you
would become the president as soon as
the President had served his second term
from Jackson Andrew Jackson to Abraham
Lincoln the Democrats dominated
controlling the presidency for 24 out of
32 years the Senate for an equal period
in the house for 22 years they
controlled all three branches together
for nearly half of that long 30 year
period and the Republicans had the same
kind of dominance from 1861 the
beginning of the Civil War
until 1933 the Republicans held the
presidency for 56 out of 72 years only
two Democrats were elected president
between Lincoln and FDR and they were
Grover Cleveland who was elected you
know the only president elected
non-consecutive Lee he won and lost and
then won again and the other was Woodrow
Wilson about whom I'll say a little bit
more later who only one because in 1912
the Republican vote was split between
William Howard Taft who was the
incumbents and Teddy Roosevelt who
challenged him who ran against him as a
third party candidate so we're talking
about a period of more than 50 years in
which the Republicans hold the
presidency and for the majority of that
time they hold one or both branches of
Congress to and from 1933 to 1965 you
see a similar kind of dominance in other
words if you look at American political
party history you see that in the
beginning the Democrats are dominant to
the incomes of a long period of
Republican dominance when the
Republicans are the majority party in
the country and can
trol all of the major institutions most
of the time and then after the New Deal
at least until say 1968 or so you have a
period in which the Democrats are again
fairly dominant since 1968 it has been
much more evenly split and it's very
hard to say that we have a dominant
political party at all right now the
Republicans of course have the president
have the the two houses of Congress
would lack the presidency but they have
30 states the governors and at least one
house in thirty states they have a
pretty solid record at the state level
but the truth is as pat caddell was
saying last night the growth industry
here is not neither in Republican
registration or Democratic registration
but an independent registration and it
looks increasingly like it won't be long
before independents are a plurality in
our politics that refuse to side with
one party or the other they refuse to
trust either party it seems in the way
that Americans used to trust one or the
other of the major parties and that
could be a problem going forward not
necessarily but it could be and will so
come back to that I think in a little
bit all right so given our task then to
look at the history and principles of
the Republican Party let's throw up our
hands in resignation at the beginning we
can't do it there's too much history so
instead I'm just going to look at a
couple of episodes in which I think the
history illustrates the principles the
conflicts the political conflicts in
history tell us something very important
about the principles of the Republican
Party I'm going to talk about very
briefly about the 1850s the beginning of
the GOP I'm going to talk a greater
length about what I call the civil war
within the Republican Party that erupted
during the Progressive Era culminating
in the 1912 election then I'm going to
talk also at some length about Ronald
Reagan because I think with all of the
attention that we have to pay to mr.
Trump
and to the vagaries of this year's
election we have sort of neglected the
most important Republican political
figure you know in the 20th century in
all probability and that's Ronald Reagan
he too was a kind of populist and we if
we don't remember that I think we risk
misunderstanding him and we also lose
some insight into Donald Trump because
the kind of populism Donald Trump Ellis
traits may be different or slightly
different from Reagan's but there was a
very popular streak to Ronald Reagan the
conservative movement has always had a
populist element in it if for no better
source think back to Bill Buckley who
famously said early in the 1960s that he
would rather be governed by the first
2,000 names in the Boston telephone book
than by the faculty at Harvard that's
often misquoted by the way as he has it
and people have him saying a hundred
names or two hundred names I it is two
thousand I mean that gets a kiss here a
little it's more populist in a certain
way and but it also gives you a little
heads you know against too small a group
of the people and then finally the
fourth thing I'll say something as I as
I have perhaps indicated already about
Trump but only very quickly and we can
pursue that further in the question and
answer period if you'd like now then the
GOP is a funny party it's always been
reluctant to think of itself as a party
and to act as a party something of
George Washington's original suspicion
of political parties as either as it
best a a nuisance and it worse to
dangerous lingers in the Republican
consciousness also Republicans have
always had as you as of course you know
a very high regard for individual rights
for human equality and human liberty and
therefore the kind of packaging of
people into groups and into interest
groups that is so natural
the operations of a political party has
struck some Republicans always has
struck some Republicans as immoral or at
least cheapening and they have tried to
stay away from that President or Lincoln
himself in the 1850s famously described
the Republican Party as consisting quote
of strange discordant and even hostile
elements gathered from the four winds
unquote and if you think about the
differences today among conservatives
and among Republicans you could see that
there's still a lot of truth in that I
mean you have pro-life conservatives you
have you have economic conservatives you
have nationalist conservatives you have
defense conservatives you have all kinds
of varieties of conservatives who come
usually can come together once every
four years and vote for the same
presidential candidate but the very
fractious nasaw of the Republican Party
and its constituencies the very
cussedness of the individuality of a lot
of Republicans means that it takes
something very strong and high to bind
together these people into a political
alliance and Lincoln of course pioneered
the original formula for this these
fractious elements have to be bound
together by service to some great
principle or perhaps to principles in
his case natural rights or individual
rights on the one hand and the social
contract or political self-government or
you could say the Union on the other
liberty and union these are the two
great original principles that gave
birth to the Republican Party they were
principles rooted in a doctrine of
nature of human nature of the kind of
beings that human beings were equal and
free visa vie one another and therefore
capable of governing themselves in
league with others forming a social
contract or a social comp
these two great principles enabled
Lincoln and the party in the 1850s to
draw on the legacy of the two probably
the two greatest figures from the
American Founding Jefferson insofar as
he was the author of the Declaration of
Independence and the doctrine of natural
rights in its American expression and
human equality and of course George
Washington as the great representative
of the Union and of patriotism above all
and above party in particular Jefferson
of course had some sides to him that
were not so favorable to Abraham Lincoln
into the Republican Party he had been of
course a slave owner he had been a
defender to some degree of the spread of
slavery in the 1820s the spread of
slavery throughout the Union whereas the
Republican Party and Lincoln were
strictly pledged to forbidding the
further spread west of slavery into the
territories of the of the Union but for
Lincoln's purposes the politically
useful the politically necessary
Jefferson was the Jefferson of the
Declaration of Independence not of the
Kentucky resolutions or any of his other
statements that were less amenable to
Republican usage Lincoln as as you as I
indicate had to resolve these two
together had to bring Jefferson and
Washington into a kind of contemporary
alliance under Republican banners but
that's exactly what he did the
Democratic Party has always that well
the Republican Party has had a kind of
ideological character therefore from the
very beginning it it took doctrine
seriously and it needed doctrine to sort
of bring people whose interest might in
some respects be discordant together the
Democratic Party has always had a
different character the Democratic Party
is the only party that for example has
has ever had a coalition building as the
essence of its party organization but
everyone has heard of the New Deal
coalition right why is that a term that
come
so easily to our lips when discussing
the Democratic Party because it
expresses really the essence of the
Democratic Party over time which has
been to bring very discordant people
together not by you know a bondage to
some moral principle like anti-slavery
necessarily but typically out of appeal
to interest and to the ability of
government to help them to move forward
in life in ways noble and perhaps
sometimes ignoble but the Democrats have
always been more comfortable with that
than the Republicans have and that
persists I think even today all right
now let me switch gears to my second
topic progressive ism this is a
something of an untold story I think
which I'll just try to bring the
rudiments of it to your attention today
the Republican Party had a great civil
war within itself which culminated in
the election of 1912 and the results of
that civil war were extremely important
to the future the 20th century future of
the of the Republican Party so let me
let me describe how what was the nature
of this war and what happened so put
yourself for a moment in the position of
a member of the Republican Party after
the Civil War hmm what do you do if
you're a Republican after your party has
saved the Union and freed the slaves
that's a hard act to follow
what's the second act what do you do
next after you've accomplished all that
for Teddy Roosevelt and his generation
this was a real question they were in
love with Lincoln they almost all of
them wrote books or essays on Abraham
Lincoln celebrating the greatness of
Lincoln aspiring to emulate Lincoln's
greatness but how to do it from their
point of view the slavery question was
solved no one was going to know
could legally be held in slavery in the
United States again the Secession
question was solved it had been
nullified as a doctrine no state was
ever going to at least in their life
certainly not in their lifetime was
going to you know attempt to to sunder
the Union in order to get its way that
would not be allowed the army will not
allow that to happen and therefore these
being the great issues of the pre-civil
war era what is left to fight about in
the Civil War after the Civil War
well Roosevelt's TR and his friends
decided the only thing they could do to
emulate Abraham Lincoln was to turn in
his spirit to the next great moral
political revolution or cause which they
thought was securing the people's
interests against the special interests
that meant opposing giant corporations
which were new economic actors on the
horizon and political machines and they
regarded those two things corporations
and political machines as the equivalent
of slavery and sections the the old
issues the old pre-civil war issues in
the name of progressive government they
had to bring a new and higher morality
to America's economic life and to its
raw political life in order to redeem
their debt to Lincoln and the Republican
Party in the Civil War and that's why it
shouldn't surprise you that most
progressives back at the turn of the
20th century most progressives were
Republicans we think today as a
progressivism as the cause of the
Democratic Party of the Liberal
Democratic Party but in the beginning
although there were certainly democratic
progressives there were more Republican
progresses progressivism was more at
home initially in the Republican Party
than in the Democratic Party and it's
because if you love Lincoln but think
that the book of American politics had
has to move on to a new chapter after
the close of the Civil War you were in a
position where you couldn't you
Lincoln's principals directly anymore in
politics slavery and secession being
solved you could use only his example
and therefore you had to transfer his
example to another field to harvest it
in the name of Lincoln's glory and his
his own actions now this this reminds me
of one of my favorite sayings about
Woodrow Wilson a member of his cabinet
said of him and this is so wonderfully
applicable to so many Democrats today a
said of him President Lincoln is a man
of high ideals but no principles and
something like that is the yeah I think
characterizes a lot of progressive
politicians today that is they have high
ideals but but by which they justify
whatever it is that they do but
principals are fewer and far between
principles that actually bind them as
opposed to liberating them in what they
might be allowed to do well a p.m.
Woodrow Wilson and Teddy Roosevelt
though they were in different parties
agreed that we were in a new age with
new problems and in order to solve them
we needed a new political science and so
something that bound together
progressives of both parties was an
enthusiasm for a new kind of political
science that came from Germany and from
England and elsewhere and that
emphasized not human nature but human
history what we had made of ourselves
over the course of history and in in
keeping with this you know the term
human rights usurps the old term natural
rights natural rights indicates quite
openly that we owe our rights to our
nature to something we didn't may
something that we receive as a kind of
gift from God or from nature itself
human rights is more ambiguous because
human rights opens the possibility that
these are the rights we have made for
ourselves over time that we have created
that we have insisted upon that we are
the source of nothing outside of us
nothing above us nothing around us like
nature we are responsible for our own
history and our nature is simply the
result of the decisions we have made
about ourselves over the course of our
history this was the the essence of the
new political science that was imported
into United States and too into American
universities around this time now Teddy
Roosevelt had a particularly interesting
application of this these new concepts
in political science to his own party
and he was in the election of 1912 we
have three major candidates leaving the
Socialist aside we have the incumbent
Republican who was William Howard Taft
very big man 300-plus pounds he was that
he had been Governor General of the
Philippines and have a friend who was
researching a book on Taft and he tells
me these stories of the you know he had
to be he was carried from village to
village by offensive Porter's when this
when the going was tough and the terrain
was steep I'm glad I wasn't one of those
Porter's but in any case he had he was
the incumbent president you had you had
Wilson who was running as a Democrat and
then you had Taft who had lost the
Republican nomination I mean you had TR
who had lost the Republican nomination
and then ran as a bull moose as a bull
moose progressive now in this line up
you have two Republicans and one
Democrat and the Democrat Wilson very
cleverly presented himself as a kind of
moderate
he was a progressive too and in
intellectual he was every bit as radical
maybe even more radical than Teddy
Roosevelt's but politically he was able
to occupy the middle ground because the
two Republicans were locked in a deadly
battle basically against each other and
Taft wanted to know why white TR had
gone to the trouble of opposing him and
now running as a third-party against it
what had he done wrong they were old
friends they were political allies they
had worked together in Washington for
quite a while and the answer is that TR
had moved far to the left by the 1912
presidential race he was calling for
measures in the states to allow state
legislators to overturn the decisions of
state supreme courts and he was by
implication though not explicitly
calling for something like that in our
national politics eventually to that the
Congress should have the power to
overturn the Supreme Court when it's in
its decisions it blocked the path to
social progress it blocked social reform
ISM he was also interested in extending
the forms of direct democracy more
deeply into our politics at the state
level and perhaps again at the national
level and so you have this civil war
within the Republican Party between TR
who is moving far left in this new
progressive agenda and the old
Republicans now gathered in support of
William Howard Taft and among these four
old friends of Roosevelt who broke with
TR because they thought that he had gone
constitutionally crazy and that he was
attacking the rudiments of American
constitutionalism with some of his
proposals were Ella who roots and Henry
Cabot Lodge great names in the
Republican parties some of them had been
senators Secretary of State's other
major positions
been held by them and they actually
broke their friendships off with TR as
well in order to oppose him here now
they lost of course in the sense that
that Taft was not re-elected he came in
third but of course TR was not elected
either but they were willing to spend a
lot of capital to keep the Teddy
Roosevelt from being elected president
in this new leftist super progressive
guys that in a sense was the first
battle in the twentieth century between
liberal Republicans and centrist and
right-wing Republicans it was the
beginning of constitutional conservatism
as a conscious ideology we didn't quite
realize it at the time because of course
Wilson wins and the whole history of the
country changes as a result of that but
the bitter bitter battle within the
Republican Party was not the first time
well what's the first time but not the
last time in the twentieth century that
the fate of the of the Republican Party
would depend upon an internal conflict
the result of this battle was of course
that the Democrat became president but
they thought Taft and and his supporters
thought that was that was a not the
worst that could have happened it was
the second worst that could have
happened the worst would have been Teddy
Roosevelt being elected how what that in
a way heroic action of these fellows in
1912 established however was that in the
coming history of the 20th century there
would still be one political party which
was open to constitutionalism which
would defend the constitutionalism at
great expense to itself there was one
political party that could become a
vehicle for conservatism though
conservatism as a conscious thing would
not arrive until the 1950s and the 1960s
many decades later but there was still
one political instrument in America open
to it because of their actions in the
election of 1912 now my third subject I
want to say something
Ragan as I say I think he's unjustly
neglected and now Reagan is a great
president let's not mince words but from
his own point of view on the single most
important issue he failed and he tells
us this in no uncertain terms in his
farewell address which is one of his
most important addresses and perhaps one
of his least known as well it was given
from the White House he was still there
he was on the way out when he gave this
address and this is what he says in that
farewell address let me just
characterize it for you here when Reagan
entered office in 1981 he called for
quote a new beginning unquote in our
politics at the meridian of his tenure
in the second inaugural he raised the
goal to what he called quote a second
american revolution of hope and
opportunity unquote a second American
Revolution that's what he thought
America needed and what he hoped to
deliver to them in his farewell address
he rejoiced that the Reagan Revolution a
term he accepted had succeeded in
reviving quote national pride and what I
call the new patriotism unquote but he
regretted that the new patriotism had
fallen short of the second American
Revolution that he still sought and that
he still regarded as necessary we need a
patriotism he said in the farewell
address grounded in thoughtfulness and
knowledge and then this passage which
came as close to a poignant admission of
defeat as anything he ever said or wrote
quote
those of us over 35 or so years of age
grew up in a different America we were
taught very directly what it means to be
an American and we absorbed almost in
the air a love of country
and an appreciation of its institutions
if you didn't get these things from your
family you got them from the
neighborhood or you could get a sense of
patriotism from school and if all else
failed you could get a sense of
patriotism from the popular culture but
now we're about to enter the 1990s and
some things have changed younger parents
aren't sure that an unambivalent
appreciation of America is the right
thing to teach modern children and as
for those who create the popular culture
well grounded patriotism is no longer
the style our spirit is back our public
spirit our patriotism is back
but we haven't reinstated he said now
Reagan admits he grew up in a different
America he meant that America had
suffered its own change of regime it was
a different country now than the one in
which he'd grown up despite its many
other proud accomplishments the Reagan
Revolution hadn't succeeded in restoring
that earlier America or more precisely
in forging a new one in which an
unambivalent patriotism could be taken
for granted in this most comprehensive
and important political task the
equivalent of a second American
Revolution he and his administration had
not succeeded or to express it more
optimistically as Reagan would have
preferred that great task remained for
his successors for us to accomplish we
have to acknowledge however that the
inability to make permanent the new
patriotism raises grave questions about
the coherence and the adequacy of
Reagan's own accounts of conservative
leadership and here I'll just give you
the conclusion of
a longer argument his ends at least as
he sketched them in many of his speeches
and to read his speeches is such a
refreshment I mean I highly recommend it
if you're feeling down at the political
news this was not that long ago and his
speeches are very good and and much in
some ways much more politically precise
and knowledgeable than you may remember
them anyway what Reagan said he wanted
to do was renew constitutional
government to take America back to the
Constitution again but that end proved
increasingly discordant with his means
which was to lead the American people by
upholding their values and this is a
term he used all the time there our
values in his acceptance speech in 1980
he said that renewing the American
Compact would require Americans quote to
trust your values our values and to hold
me responsible for living up to them
unquote but today's ambivalence
patriotism he warned as he left office
is the sign of a people that doesn't
trust its values and may not even know
what its values are worse from the point
of view of a conservative leader it is
the sign of a people that can't be
trusted to trust its values what then
becomes of what he called the special
special kind of compact between the
people and their leaders by requiring
leaders to be guided primarily by the
people's values Reagan leave Statesman
hostage to the spirit of their age
unable to make a new beginning much less
a Novus Ordo seclorum as the American
founders had done in liberal times like
ours it is difficult for conservative
leaders to reform re-educate or refound
public opinion while also obeying it
Reagan like to repeat Tom
Dane's spirited boast you may have heard
him say the seed said it several times
quotes we have it in our power to begin
the world over again
you know that's sweet
it's so American I mean straight from
Tom Paine to Ronald Reagan but what did
Reagan mean by that why was he quoting
Tom Paine we have it in our power to
begin the world over again you know
Reagan drew criticism from conservatives
some conservatives for indulging Tom
Payne's radicalism but what Reagan was
affirming was that the American people
had the power or the capacity to begin
the world of American politics over
again to return to the spirit of
American politics before modern
liberalism when despite his best efforts
they did not do so when ambivalent
patriotism prevailed it through and to
doubt whether they ever possessed such a
capacity to make the world over or to
begin the world over again to make the
second revolution second American
Revolution that he talked about
it's also possible of course that the
political moment simply wasn't ripe back
then or that the people's leaders
including Reagan himself were too
progressive because they were too
conservative they could never make a
clean break even in thoughts with the
dominance progressive canons of popular
leadership and values and all the rest
of it they didn't know how to be
founders perhaps then the route back to
a second American Revolution involves
taking the first one more seriously
reconsidering the virtues of the
founders the principles of the
Declaration of Independence in the
Constitution and Lincoln's example as a
Republican president who was able in
effect to begin the world over again and
to take America back to the Constitution
back to its anti-slavery foundations in
a situation piled high with difficulty
of every sort so let me conclude
by saying something has promised about
Trump and our situation today mr. mr.
Trump is much less aware than Ronald
Reagan was of what we have lost
politically as a nation over the last 50
or so years but he has a similar faith
in the American people and he's assisted
by the fact that the the liberal regime
today is far less popular than it was in
1980 it is not far more it is however
far more powerful than it was in 1980
but it is far less popular I mean if you
look at the two great tendencies in
American government over the last
generation what are they increasing
power in Washington increasing distrust
of Washington they correlate almost
precisely and yet we can't seem to
reverse the impulsion of power to
Washington
Trump's example has also showed us that
many Republicans today as in the
Progressive Era itself are really
believers in the progressive regime
believers in the liberal regime prepared
even to vote for Hillary in order to
rather than vote for Trump or prepare to
vote for Hillary in order to sustain and
protect the rules of the game as the
political game is now currently being
played in Washington which is
overwhelmingly a set of progressive
rules it's hard to win the game when the
other side writes the rules and that is
a fundamental problem for Republicans
and conservatives in today's situation
if you can't change the rules of the
game you can't win the game and that
unfortunately is the dilemma that the
sixteen other candidates against whom
Trump ran were not able to escape they
they failed I think precisely because
the people the Republican electorate
said to them these these are very fine
people but none of them is a game
changer
none of them can win under the current
circumstances of course it's not clear
that Trump can win either he has to win
first before we can see what he can do
but he he in a way is still finds
himself like Reagan in the same
situation in which he has a political
class a political system headed by a
political class that is increasingly
alienated from basic American moral and
political norms that is increasingly
anti-constitutional in its in its effect
and in its purposes and so I'll leave
you with this thought you know it used
to be said that as I said at the
beginning disagreements in American
politics tended not to be about
fundamentals there tended to be a
consensus on the fundamentals and a
disagreement on methods how to pursue
the goals that we all agreed upon but I
think that's less and less true now than
it was thirty years ago or fifty years
ago you know we have if you listen to
political speeches you hear about two
constitutions the Republicans and maybe
still a few Democrats talk about the
original Constitution of the United
States the 1787 document as amended but
liberals prefer to talk about the living
Constitution now heretofore the liberal
Constitution the Liberals have defended
that Constitution not as an alternative
to the original Constitution but simply
as a way of implementing it a way of
keeping it up to date and and you know
ocher all but I think the truth is
increasingly on display which is that
the living Constitution is not a
different route to the same goal the
living Constitution is a different
Constitution and so we have in a system
which has two competing constitutions
you cannot have unity you cannot have a
healthy two-party system
because you lack a healthy one-party
system that underlies it and going
forward I think that is really the huge
question that hovers over American
politics are we under the same
Constitution that Teddy Roosevelt and
Abraham Lincoln and George Washington
promulgated and were under or are we
under a constitution we know not the
origins of or the ends of and that has
never been approved by any sort of
democratic process or constitutional
democratic process in American history
in it I think in any case we're soon
going to learn a lot more about what the
principles of the Republican Party mean
for the unfolding history of our times
thank you very much
so we have time for a few questions well
thank you for your presentation you
alluded to earlier that after the Civil
War the african-american community
aligned itself with the Republican Party
yes would you comment on what
circumstances allowed that transition to
go to the opposite party and do you see
today any possibility of a return well
there's I mean the usual story as usual
explanation is that Franklin Roosevelt
picked up the votes of southern blacks
and northern blacks in the New Deal as
an alternative to the to economic
despair under Hoover and the Republicans
and it's true that you know that the
Republican presidents of the 1920s
Harding Coolidge and Hoover enjoyed very
high black support I mean astronomically
high compared to today they received a
majority of black support so something
did happen now there are recent studies
that suggest the erosion was more
gradual than that and that even in the
1920s and in the teens there had been
some erosion of Republican of a
Republican support from blacks but it
still it seems to be the case that the
30s were the climacteric when it really
hits when the change really hit and you
know Martin Luther King Martin Luther
King's father was a Republican and you
know as far as support for the civil
rights act in the 64 vote went the
Republicans to deliver it a much higher
percentage of their votes than Democrats
did because the Southern Democrats still
existed then and were the principal
obstacle to it all that has tended to be
forgotten
mm-hmm and I must say one one thing that
I thought courageous and correct about
Trump is the his call to black voters
and Hispanic voters to look at their our
situation again and and take a chance
you know what do they have to lose as he
as he rightly put it I think and you
know the legacy of the party of Lincoln
is still there and it could be I think
powerfully brought to life again but it
would take someone to do it I mean and
and Trump has at least begun that kind
of move but there's a lot a lot of
territory yet to travel yes oh sorry I
have no power here
thank you for coming to speak today you
mentioned earlier in your speech that
more and more people were becoming
independent and that this was
potentially a problem
could you elaborate on this is just a
statement on the parties that they
distrust or a bigger problem in and of
itself well it's a problem if you're a
Republican or a Democrat but it's also a
problem in a way for the country because
if you're if you're not a member you if
you belong to no organized political
party which doesn't mean you're a
Democrat that was the old joke you know
for the 30s but if you belong to no
organized political party you have no
way to influence American politics in
the long term you don't have a primary
process you don't have a way of
selecting candidates except on the fly
and you have no direction for the party
you have no party principles you have no
party goals now if you turn of course if
you if you if you're talking not about
simply not registering with one of the
parties but forming a third party that's
a different situation because there has
been one example in American history
where with the collapse of a major party
a minor party took its place and that
was the Republican Party in the 1850s
but it's obviously a hard thing to do
and the two parties have made it harder
because they have changed the laws the
elected the the election laws in ways
that make it difficult for third parties
to compete with them and that wasn't the
case in the 19th century at least not
nearly so much but it is now so it's
it's even harder than it once was
oh my goodness you said a great deal and
you said it all very well my second
question is predicated on your answer to
the first do you have mr. Trump's ear
and the second question if your answer
is yes
could you convey to him from me two
points wait a minute I haven't answered
the first question yeah I said if first
go ahead that he needs to talk about the
Constitution in the way you talked about
it with the kind of respect and honor
with which you spoke about it and and
that is so vital to this country and
secondly Wow change his slogan to the
refounding of America that's a lot more
specific than make America great again
all right well as thank you for those
suggestions as for the first question no
I don't have his ear but
I remember the I can't think of his name
right now but a noted conservative
humorist used to used to tell this joke
about another conservative he said this
guy you know he's he's rock-ribbed
red-blooded American conservative and
you wouldn't you wouldn't believe it but
it's true that this guy who seemed so
purely red-state really has the heart of
a liberal and he keeps it in a jar on
his desk
so I I don't have mr. Trump's ear in a
jar on a desk or anywhere else but if I
get it I'll pass along your suggestions
time for one more question you spoke you
spoke highly of Ronald Reagan and I
agree with you you seem to be the last
president that was an American in that
he understood for all I couldn't see for
Constitution 1776 and many of us hoped
that we had turned the tide and would go
back to being America then he turned out
to be just a little bump in the road to
serfdom he now have a president who
openly proclaims that he wants to
destroy the American Founding Fathers
but this brought us to this state there
must be a moral principle that cost the
Conservatives to keep failing and the
bad guys to keep winning
all right good did you hear that
question okay the question is lamenting
that Reagan who you know in comparably
the most able conservative or republican
presidents of our era yet turns out to
be only a speed bump on the road to
serfdom and so we have a president who
is openly or at least his you know
contemptuous of the Constitution and
seems to prosper despite that but I
would say two things one look we won the
Cold War
if it had not been from Ronald Reagan I
don't think we would have won the Cold
War that is a huge achievement it is
it's an achievement that continues to
shape our world and to reverberate in
positive directions but it is not an
unforgettable achievement
the current generation has no
recollection of the Cold War and hence
we have to transmit to them we can't
just
bask in the truth that we won the Cold
War we have to transmit that fact and
all that it means and all that that
victory represented but the second thing
I would say is the president I have the
distinction I suppose or the the
unfortunate distinction of having
written a book about him and the truth
is he he hides his disagreements with
the Constitution he goes out of his way
like FDR did to to to describe a
narrative of America that links him
President Obama to FDR and to Abraham
Lincoln and to the founding fathers
he is he is very clever at this his
story suggests that if the founding
fathers were here today they would be
wholeheartedly approving of all of his
measures and incredible as that sounds
Republicans who have a much better and
more truthful story to tell don't really
talk about it mr. Trump does not talk
about his connection to Abraham Lincoln
he has mentioned him in one or two
speeches but it's not a theme I mean
it's just you know I mentioned in one or
two spaces speeches he hasn't told the
story of America in a way that
identifies support for him with support
for constitutionalism for Lincoln e'en
style understanding of the moral
purposes of American politics he could
still do that but the fact is that the
Democrats have been have been much more
spellbinding in their ability to weave
themselves into the warp and woof of
American history and to lead you to the
conclusion that
that they understand the founders better
than the end then the founders
understood themselves and if you look at
this I mean it's it's quite amazing but
many of his major speeches for example
the second inaugural which we just heard
a couple of years ago the second
inaugural begins with a long quotation
from the Declaration of Independence he
actually quotes these documents at some
length in order to indicate not only is
he not an American not only is he not
anti-american but in fact he is as
American as the Declaration of
Independence and we have not Republicans
have not done a good job of countering
that story and they must begin to before
it's too late
thank you thank you all